the lottery is literally a scam so
you're a state government in the early
2000s and you want to collect more tax
dollars but you have a big problem
you're already taxing the rich and
middle class A lot if you increase their
taxes they will vote you out of office
and raising taxes on poor people is not
an option unless you want riots in the
streets but you still want to squeeze
more money out of all of those poor
people without them noticing of course
so you set up a little game called the
lottery you tell them that for a tiny
fee they could become multi-millionaires
overnight and that every cent they spend
on lottery tickets is going to a good
cause like educating the youth then you
trigger some fomo by telling them that
this is their only chance to get rich
and voila you have millions of poor
people lined up to hand you the little
money they have click the link in the
pinned comment to learn how the world
really works